si vous le voulez bien
on va démarrer à l'heure
et ben écoutez voilà
Monsieur Madame chers collègue
nous poursuivons les travaux de
président de notre mission qui
malheureusement est absent aujourd'hui
et j'ai l'honneur de représenter aux
côtés de notre rapporteur voilà qui a
une lourde mission
comme vous vous en doutez alors voilà
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant de carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en recevant
vous-même messieurs monsieur Marouane
Lahou
voilà président de l'activité de Private
équité et de tiké au capital voilà
monsieur lahoux vous avez notamment été
directeur général délégué d'Airbus en
charge de la stratégie du marketing
ainsi que président du Groupement des
industries françaises aéronautiques et
spatiales avant de rejoindre le groupe
tikéo capital avant de présider
l'activité de Private équité vous avez
en particulier été président Ace capital
partenaire fond d'investissement qui est
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique la
défense est aussi bien sûr la sécurité
monsieur Lahou est accompagné par
Monsieur Philippe bottry président de
BPCS et qui fut notamment directeur des
affaires publiques France du groupe
Airbus
donc cette réunion est captée sachez-le
et diffusé en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo à la
demande
messieurs notre mission d'information
comprend des membres issus de
différentes commissions qui représentent
l'ensemble des groupes politiques du
Sénat le développement des filières de
biocarburant et de carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert
représente nous le savons tous un enjeu
important pour permettre à la France et
à l'Union européenne d'atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050 mais aussi pour notre
souveraineté et la compétitivité de
notre économie
le transport aérien compte tenu des
caractéristiques physiques propres
avions présentent des enjeux
particuliers les carburants d'aviation
durable sont aujourd'hui au centre des
attentions tentent à l'échelon nationale
qu'à l'échelon européen un accord sur le
projet de règlement refioule
Europe
aviation vient d'être trouvé entre le
Parlement européen et le Conseil par
ailleurs l'hydrogène en tant que tel
donne lieu à un certain nombre de
recherches de projets industriels
alors votre regard d'industriel et de
financier nous intéresse bien évidemment
et doublement car nous mesurons
l'ampleur des investissements à réaliser
ainsi que les enjeux stratégiques
sous-jacents notre rapporteur monsieur
Vincent capo Canella vous a adressé un
questionnaire
danse
qui peut vous servir de guide mais vous
pouvez l'introduire votre propos comme
vous le souhaitez et pour se faire vous
aurez un temps que nous donnons monsieur
le rapporteur d'intervention de
présentation
une vingtaine de minutes pour permettre
les échanges ensuite avec les membres de
cette commission je passerai ensuite
donc la parole à notre rapporteur puis à
l'ensemble de nos collègues afin qu'il
puisse vous relancer peut-être sur les
questions lesquelles vous n'auriez pas
suffisamment répondu ou bien sûr à
d'autres questions qui les intéressent
et bien sûr vous pourrez nous
transmettre ultérieurement des réponses
écrites aux questions qui vous ont été
adressés je vous aide monsieur Lahou la
parole pour dans 15 à 20 minutes merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président
je le rapporteur madame messieurs les
sénateurs
le questionnaire que vous m'avez adressé
était non seulement dense mais
particulièrement complet puisqu'il m'a
donné la trame de mon intervention
liminaire je vais essayer de me limiter
dans le temps je pourrais en parler
pendant
des heures cela a été mon cela est
toujours mon métier et c'est un métier
de passionné l'aéronautique donc excusez
mais
mes envolés de temps en temps
libérez-vous
[Musique]
le
la question de la décarbonation de
l'aviation est un enjeu fondamental pour
cette filière industrielle
qui je me permets de le rappeler ici et
sans doute la seule filière
française
européenne premier française réellement
d'excellence dans le sens où tous ces
résultats
quel que soit le critère d'évaluation
que l'on considère en font le plus fort
contributeur à la balance commerciale un
très gros employeur en France
il y a d'autres filières qui sont
réputés en France mais qui importe et
qui exporte et qui font du qui font du
on va dire du trading pardonner mon
pardonner mon français là on a une on a
une filière qui est très localisée
même si il y a déjà beaucoup de
la valeur ajoutée qui se font en dehors
et
c'est surtout une filière qui est portée
par un mouvement séculaire
en termes de croissance de la demande
mouvement séculaire qui n'est pas prête
de ce de s'affaiblir j'ai le souvenir
pendant
le juste après le premier confinement
d'avoir échangé avec des industriels
avec des avec des financiers qui me
disaient mais il y avait deux avions à
Roissy donc
le retour de l'aéronautique c'est pas
pour demain ça se fera ça se fera jamais
et au fond cette
demande de voyage la croissance du
trafic aérien et une règle très simple
par zone géographique c'est à peu près
deux fois la croissance économique
de la zone considérée ici on regarde ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui la croissance
économique en Europe c'est 3% environ la
croissance du trafic aérien en Europe
c'est 4,1% donc il y a un peu de marge
encore en termes de croissance mais si
on fait de la projection juste linéaire
sans sans réfléchir on se rend compte
que d'ici la fin de la décennie la
croissance économique en Europe sera à
peu près 2,7%. et la croissance du
trafic aérien sera elle deux fois plus
c'est-à-dire 5,5 et j'ai les mêmes
statistiques pour l'Amérique du Nord
j'ai les mêmes statistiques pour
l'Amérique latine l'Afrique et cette
cette évolution
elle est
incontestable indiscutable le besoin de
voyage le besoin de mobilité est un
besoin vital au même titre
que le besoin de sécurité de nourriture
et de confort
on ne va pas désinventer l'avion
partant de ce principe et on pourra en
discuter en discuter
partant de ce principe
l'aviation l'aéronautique française
l'aéronautique européenne et devant un
choix
où elle prend le commandement elle prend
la direction de la décarbonation et elle
devient la filière industrielle qui fixe
les standards
ou bien
elle décroît
et à ce moment-là d'autres prendront le
relais
et il y aura une aviation qui répondra
aux besoins
de transport qui répondra aux besoins de
mobilité mais ça ne sera pas la nôtre
le fait de fixer le standard elle sera
d'ailleurs pas forcément des carbonées
le fait de fixer les standards de dire
un avion ça va être décarboné en 2035
est une façon de garder le leadership de
garder le commandement la direction
de la course
en matière d'aéronautique
c'est un choix qui est extrêmement
difficile Guillaume Faury le patron
d'Airbus dit que l'aéronautique a connu
quatre évolutions
la première c'est au début du 20e siècle
puisque à peine 10 ans avant l'ordre
Kelvin qui était un très grand physicien
disait il est impossible de faire voler
un plus lourd que l'air
quand Clément Ader décolle c'est là où
je diffère un peu avec Faurie
Faurie 10 et les frères right moi je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
c'est Clément Ader qui a décollé en
premier
quand Clément Ader décolle pour la
première fois
il va à l'encontre
de d'une affirmation péremptoire d'un
des plus grands physiciens de son époque
ça c'est la première révolution
la deuxième révolution c'est la
révolution de la sécurité en vol
la durée de vie moyenne d'un avion juste
après la Première Guerre mondiale était
d'une trentaine de minutes oui vous avez
bien entendu une trentaine de minutes
la troisième révolution c'est beaucoup
plus tard c'est au milieu des années 60
c'est la démocratisation du vol le fait
que cela soit accessible voyage aérien
devienne accessible
au plus grand nombre
et aujourd'hui nous sommes au devant de
la quatrième révolution qui est un avion
des carbonées
alors comme
comme tout ce que fait cette cette
filière industrielle qui est très bien
organisée en France et en Europe entre
le GIFAS et l'ASD
nous avons pris à bras le corps la
question de la décarbonation et nous
avons mis en place des plans
alors je ne suis pas bien ancien
président d'honneur du vivas je ne suis
pas le plus à même de vous décrire le
détail de ce plan je laisse le soin à
ceux qui sont de le faire mais
c'est un plan structuré qui repose sur
un certain nombre de solutions et qui
doit garantir en 2035 le vol d'un avion
0 carbone avec comme objectif la
décarbonation complète du transport
aérien en 2050 le temps de remplacer les
avions en vol et de faire le j'allais
dire le l'évolution normale des flottes
alors 2035 ça peut paraître lointain
2050 ça peut paraître encore plus
lointain mais à l'échelle de la vie d'un
avion à l'échelle de la vie du transport
aérien c'est demain matin
et donc non seulement il y a un plan
mais les travaux ont commencé
la R&D n'a pas commencé hier ou
avant-hier elle a commencé depuis
quelques années déjà en matière de
réduction des émissions Le j'allais dire
la marche que nous franchissons le saut
que nous que nous que nous lançons
aujourd'hui c'est de dire ok ce n'est
pas réduire c'est zéro
quelles sont les solutions techniques là
aussi je ne suis pas le plus à même pour
en parler mais ce que l'on constate
c'est que l'essentiel
de la de du plan repose sur les
carburants durables on va parler de
carburant durable un peu plus en détail
il y a un petit 13% de du budget
réduction
des émissions qui provient de ce qu'on
appelle technologie nouvelle
et technologies nouvelles c'est
hydrogène directement employé
dans les avions ou électricité
il y a beaucoup d'autres petits bouts
dans ce budget de réduction des
émissions
un que l'on est que l'on évoque rarement
mais qui est très important c'est
l'optimisation des trajectoires
l'amélioration du contrôle
quand vous faites Paris Amsterdam
aujourd'hui en avion
on peut poser la question est-il
pertinent de faire Paris Amsterdam en
avion pour un passager ça se discute
pour certains fret
c'est inéluctable il faut le faire quand
vous faites Paris Amsterdam vous
franchissez un nombre important
ça peut être quand vous avez de la
chance c'est trois quand vous avez pas
de chance c'est plutôt 5 ou 6
zone de contrôle à chaque transition
dans une zone de contrôle vous perdez du
temps
vous consommez du pétrole vous émettez
du CO2 le temps d'attendre dans les
aéroports le temps d'attente dans les
airs tout ça c'est toutes ces
optimisations de trajectoire sont
extrêmement importantes
si on veut vraiment attaquer la question
de des émissions par tous les côtés je
vais pas aller plus loin la danse ça va
nous emmener ça va nous amener dans
beaucoup trop de détails mais c'est pour
vous donner
un aperçu de la de la granularité de
l'analyse qui a été faite par le par le
les équipes évidemment des grands
donneurs d'ordre mais les équipes du
GIFAS aussi sur
ce plan de décarbonation
je vais me concentrer sur les carburants
durables
à l'évidence
il y a plusieurs filières il y a
plusieurs procédés on va commencer par
j'allais dire le plus immédiat et aller
vers peut-être le plus lointain le plus
immédiat c'est de raffiner
des déchets raffinés de l'huile de
friture entre guillemets mais pas que
l'huile de friture il y a beaucoup
d'autres
la biomasse bon
cette
cette méthode là elle a déjà fait
aujourd'hui sa preuve technique puisque
il y a des avions qui ont volé avec 100%
de carburant issus de cette filière
deux problèmes la disponibilité de la
matière première
il faut aller la chercher la biomasse
c'est pas
si on veut industrialiser le procédé et
puis deuxièmement
les raffineries c'est à dire qu'il faut
il faut détourner des des tranches de
raffinerie de du raffinage de pétrole
fossiles vers versa tout ça n'est pas
compliqué c'est juste l'organisation
industrielle
évidemment
la bio enfin le fioul
issu de la biomasse
pose le même problème que tous les
fiouls synthétiques c'est le coup
à quel moment on a un volume suffisant
pour que cela soit compétitif et il ne
s'agit pas de trouver
un euro pour un euro en termes de prix
du litre de kérosène il s'agit de
trouver
suffisamment de volume pour avoir un
prix qui permette aux compagnies
aériennes d'opérer dans des conditions
acceptables pour faire à la fois du
passager et du fret
ça c'est un bout du spectre l'autre bout
du spectre qui est un peu le Graal de la
de la de des carburants durables c'est
le i fuel c'est-à-dire le carburant
complètement synthétique où on part avec
du CO2 capturé
avec de l'hydrogène vert ou mieux encore
de l'hydrogène bleue
et par des procédés chimiques connus
depuis longtemps avec des usines
compétitives là aussi on est capable de
combiner pour faire du du carburant
d'aviation
là aussi il y a pas de problématique
technique
très très difficile
il y a juste que on capture pas assez de
CO2
et que le CO2 capturé comme l'hydrogène
vert comme l'hydrogène bleue ne sont pas
disponibles aujourd'hui à des prix qu'on
peut titifs
l'essentiel de l'hydrogène aujourd'hui
qui est disponible c'est d'hydrogène
marron au mieux c'est-à-dire de
l'hydrogène obtenu par craquage
d'hydrocarbure celui-là il faut le
mettre de côté
mais filière prometteuse là aussi pour
avoir du carburant durable
je me je me permets peut-être à ce stade
de
souligner que toute la filière
aéronautique et complètement orienté
vers cette décarbonation je l'ai déjà
dit mais que ce soit au niveau des
donneurs d'or mais aussi au niveau de la
de des sous-traitants au niveau de la
chaîne de valeur de la chaîne logistique
de l'ensemble des participants nous
sommes tous orientés je dis nous puisque
je ticket au capital est investisseur
dans cette chaîne
de valeur chez les dans les
sous-traitants
l'aéronautique finalement est très bien
organisé il a suffi que Airbus puis
Boeing s'affront puis Ji puis
Rolls-Royce donc puis d'assaut aviation
donc les donneurs d'ordies l'aviation on
va la décarboner pour que tout le monde
s'aligne et que tout le monde travaille
dans ce sens-là
un petit mot sur Tiki au capital nous
avons lancé en 2018
un premier fond de décarbonation alors
c'était pas du tout un fond aéronautique
on a on s'est lancé dans la
décarbonation c'est le fond dit T2 où on
investit aussi bien on a investi et puis
on est sorti d'un chauffagiste parce que
le chauffage des bâtiments les passoires
thermiques enfin je ne vous fais pas de
d'explication longue là-dessus on voit
bien que il y a une
il y a quelques
quelques tonnes à gagner quelques
milliers de tonnes à gagner en termes en
termes d'émission donc on fait ça un
groupe qui s'appelle le groupe rognon
mais on a aussi investi dans une
entreprise qui s'appelle euro groupe qui
fait qui faisait des moteurs électriques
pour électroménager et qui aujourd'hui
fournit le tiers des moteurs électriques
des voitures électriques ça c'est ce que
fait le groupe ticketo dans le même à la
même époque nous avons pris la décision
de faire l'acquisition de d'une
entreprise s'appelle Ace management
connu depuis le début des années 2000
pour avoir investi dans l'aéronautique
et en
2000 donc on fait l'acquisition fin 2018
en 2020 on lance le quatrième fond
aéronautique de cette société qui était
là pour soutenir les entreprises en
sortie de covid et
également pour consolider et préparer la
reprise puisque notre hypothèse de
travail était que la reprise allait
arriver la reprise aéronautique allait
arriver
à l'évidence dans les dans les points
clés du fond dès ce moment là il
s'agissait de d'être prêt à investir
dans les efforts de décarbonation de la
filière alors comment on décarbonne
quand on est un sous-traitant quand on
est un avionneur on voit à peu près
quand on est motoriste c'est encore plus
clair mais quand on est sous-traitant
quel rôle pouvons-nous jouer en matière
de décarbonation déjà il y a la
décarbonation des usines
c'est à dire que les procédés de
fabrication les
l'énergie consommée pour fabriquer des
avions elle-même doit reposer sur une
énergie la plus décarbonée possible et
là il y a un travail d'investissement
dans l'appareil productif qui est qui
est au cœur de notre de notre stratégie
d'investissement
il y a aussi la participation à
la fabrication des des pièces des
sous-ensemble des des
composants qui vont entrer dans la
fabrication de moteur plus efficace ou
d'aéronef plus léger puisque quand c'est
plus léger ça consomme moins d'énergie
etc
et
nous avons
fait cela avec le fond que nous avons
levé en 2020 que nous avons déjà
pratiquement complètement déployés je me
permets de signaler que nous avons pu
éviter
les défaillances d'entreprise du secteur
à ce jour il y en a pas eu mais pas une
seule
nous avons fait quelques sauvetages
emblématiques ça c'est sur l'aspect
sortie de covid mais nous avons surtout
à fait progresser la consolidation du
secteur pour avoir des sous-traitants
plus fort plus
plus résilient plus capable de répondre
à la demande qui est massive aujourd'hui
en termes de montée en cadence on n'a
jamais connu une montée en cadence aussi
raide
et en même temps préparer la
décarbonation
nous sommes sur le point de lancer la
levée de notre 5e fond
pas tout de suite tout de suite mais ici
la fin de l'année nous nous engageons la
suite
de ce de cette course à la montée en
cadence d'un côté à la décarbonation de
l'aviation de l'autre
si je si j'essaye de résumer ce que je
viens de dire jusque là et je pense que
ce faisant j'aurais tenu mais le contrat
des 20 minutes
le transport aérien
la loi des deux fois
la croissance du PNB elle est toujours
vérifiée c'est une loi c'est une loi
empirique qu'on a observé depuis le
début des années 70 elle est toujours là
et
la filière est organisée elle a lancé
tout un plan qui doit se dérouler entre
maintenant et 2035 pour arriver à un
avion 0 carbone et jusqu'en 2050 pour
avoir arrivé à une aviation zéro carbone
au cœur du débat il y a les carburants
durables
puisque les nouvelles technologies dans
ce plan ne compte que pour 13%
et qui dit carburant durable dit deux
problèmes
en quantité suffisante et deuxièmement
produire des volumes suffisants pour
avoir des prix compétitifs même si les
prix compétitifs ne sont pas
1 euro pour un euro en comparaison d'un
litre de kérosène durable par rapport à
un litre de kérosène fossile
je finirai sur une note un peu plus
lyrique
je suis un ingénieur je suis entré dans
ce métier en 1986 à une époque où
la France et l'Europe aérospatiale
avaient des ambitions énormes on pensait
qu'on a qu'on pouvait conquérir le monde
c'est ce qui m'a attiré comme je
l'ingénieur plutôt que d'aller faire
autre chose
je crois qu'on a réussi et cette ce
succès à porter Airbus mais pas carabus
toute la toute la filière elle est sur
le toit du monde
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de donner à mes
à mes enfants
qui ont envie de faire ce même métier
une perspective une rêve
qui va devenir réalité et cette
perspective c'est bien la décarbonation
c'est bien de réinventer l'aviation de
réinventer l'aéronautique et l'espace
pour un monde plus durable
écoutez merci peut-être deux trois de ma
part trois questions courtes avant de
passer la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur
des carboneur 2035 ça veut dire que
c'est pour la France
ça veut dire qu'il faut que tout le
monde joue le jeu est-ce que sur un plan
international les gens auront la même
dynamique et la même politique avec les
mêmes objectifs
quand on dit un avion décarboné
c'est Airbus qui a cette ambition c'est
un avion Airbus des carboné dès qu'on
dit un avion Airbus des carboné ça
implique déjà les quatre nations Airbus
au minimum
la chaîne de la chaîne de valeur
d'Airbus va bien au-delà des 4 pays mais
l'essentiel de la valeur est contenue
dans les quatre pays donc il y a déjà un
espoir que nous ne soyons pas les seuls
à prêcher dans le désert puisque si
c'est un avion Airbus c'est un avion qui
concerne l'Europe de l'Ouest on va dire
pour être pour être assez large
la question c'est votre question elle
est elle est elle est encore plus
percutante si on parle de 2050 c'était
une aviation des carbonées
à partir du moment où Airbus a
puisse à frappe puis enfin la filière
française on parlait d'aviation des
carbonées
la filière nord-américaine a emboîté le
pas
et donc on a réussi
à fixer le standard pour les concurrents
existants
la question c'est finalement est-ce
qu'un nouvel entrant pour ne pas le
nommer le constructeur chinois est-ce
que lui va s'embarrasser autant de
questions de décarbonation
et je crois à
la je sais pas seulement c'est pas
seulement un acte de foi il y a des il y
a des faits tangibles qui le confirment
mais je crois beaucoup à la
à la précédente si j'ose dire du leader
si le si le patron d'un secteur dit on
va faire comme ça
il est assez rare que d'autres fassent
l'inverse
donc je suis assez convaincu et les
signes les premiers signes que l'on
perçoit venant d'autres parties du monde
c'est qu'aujourd'hui plus personne ne
conçoit de
de construire de réaliser un avion de
ligne
s'il n'est pas décarboné
il y a d'autres sujets il y a d'autres
aspects d'autres domaines de l'aviation
ce qu'il faut pas se limiter à
l'aviation commerciale mais
on va dire les 80% de l'aviation
aujourd'hui tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut des carboner merci
dernière question courte
parliez de l'optimisation des
trajectoires et j'aurais voulu savoir
dans votre esprit dans vos études quelle
était la distance minimum qui
permet de de développer l'aviation et
celle qui l'interdire
c'est une question c'est une question
assez délicate parce que
une question assez délicate parce que au
fond c'est une heure de vol
c'est une heure de vol mais une heure de
vol ça peut être très
ça peut être très long en distance et
très court en distance selon
combien de temps vous attendez en fait
mon point je parle je parle de du point
inverse plutôt que de dire voilà la
distance minimum
je dis il faut essayer d'éliminer
tous les temps
inutiles où les moteurs tournent
alors il y en a déjà au sol
si vous prenez des vols court courrier
au moyen courrier essayez la prochaine
fois de comptabiliser combien de temps
le moteur tourne alors que vous êtes au
point d'attente ou que vous êtes on vous
dit il y a un créneau pourquoi il y a un
créneau c'est une question
d'organisation
c'est une question d'organisation du
contrôle donc
c'est une heure de vol grosso modo mais
mais dans une heure de vol on peut faire
beaucoup de distance on peut faire très
peu de distance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
brillant Lahoud de là-haut merci de
cette présentation et d'avoir
situé les choses avec une forme
d'enthousiasme et de raison alors vous
avez une connaissance mondiale du sujet
une expérience industrielle majeure qui
fait plaisir au bord de la commission
parce que on est toujours en recherche
d'experts qui soient capable de nous
parler des sujets tout en ayant la
distance qui convient je crois que c'est
le cas alors vous direz sans doute aussi
en termes de financement comment envoyer
les choses parce que vous n'êtes pas
trop de du fond aérophone des management
et nous ce qui nous intéresse aussi
savoir comment tout ce petit monde
industriel y compris la sous-traitance
se met en situation d'aller vers la
décarbonation et d'y contribuer on a
aussi le sentiment que tout ceci
procédera sans doute d'innovation
qu'elles sont peut-être pas toutes sur
la table peut-être y a-t-il là aussi des
ressorts des choses que vous avez pu
repérer ou en tout cas un discours à
avoir sur comment la France peut
continuer d'encourager l'innovation à la
recherche parce que on a bien un
sentiment que parfois il y a des doutes
sur la pérennité dans un certain nombre
de de financement je pense notamment ce
qu'on appelle le corak pour ceux qui
ceux qui connaissent
sur l'idée du standard
est-ce que vous diriez que Boeing et
Airbus aujourd'hui sont sur la même
ligne
sachant que il faut aborder la question
de
des annonces qui avaient été faites il y
a quelques années de ça par la France
notamment un peu sous forme de
planification on avait dit là on
arrivera à l'hydrogène alors aujourd'hui
on a quand même cette idée que c'est
plutôt les carburants de la version
durable pour prendre une formule qui
vont permettre la décarbonation il y a
toujours un débat donc qu'est-ce qu'il
en est de l'hydrogène de votre point de
vue et on a compris que pour Boeing
c'était pas le sujet alors je crois
qu'on doit voir des représentants de
boeington d'ailleurs mais quel est votre
point de vue sur l'hydrogène et ensuite
est-ce que aujourd'hui sur les
carburants de la version durable les
deux les deux grands tiennent le même
discours est-ce qu'on va avec
effectivement un standard là-dessus il y
a un sujet purement technique quand même
l'homologation qui est pas faite au-delà
des 50% alors vous me direz on est
tellement bas aujourd'hui qu'avant
d'arriver à 50% on a le temps de
résoudre cette affaire là quand même
mais voilà comment vous voyez tout ça
alors on a bi ocarburant
et ifuge on avait un centre d'audition
encore ce matin ensemble je me tourner
vers Béatrice notamment un gosse qui
était avec dans l'audition et un certain
nombre nous disent mais qu'est-ce que
vous attendez en France pour
aller beaucoup plus loin sur les
biocarburants pour l'aéronautique un
certain nombre de grands aéroports ils
sont déjà
comment vous voyez ce sujet là est-ce
que vous vous dites il y a vraiment
quelque chose de faire de très vite sur
ce plan là alors if you vous allez très
bien expliquer merci de le faire avec
des mots simples mais ça c'est le
politique technicien sans doute qui nous
parle et on comprend tout évidemment ça
nous rassure mais il faut je comprends
quand même que pour vous la filière est
pas forcément battue
mais là aussi
point de technologie qu'on du point de
vue financement comment vous voyez tout
ça voilà c'est quelques questions dans
un premier temps
merci beaucoup je
le principe
c'est là aussi c'est un acte de foi les
ingénieurs savent tout faire il suffit
juste de leur poser le problème
donc quand on parle de if you
on va y arriver c'est pas je ne dis pas
que je ne dis pas qu'on n'est pas
on a un problème insurmontable la
science correspondante la technologie
correspondante n'ont rien de sorcier
la seule question c'est
l'investissement industriel
commençons par le commencement
commençons par l'hydrogène
on parle beaucoup d'hydrogène vert
tous les ans la quantité d'hydrogène
vert ou d'hydrogène bleue augmente
mais on est encore loin d'avoir cette
hydrogène
que tout le monde appelle de ses
hydrogène des carbonée si j'ose dire
aujourd'hui l'hydrogène soit il se
produit 70 millions de tonnes
d'hydrogène dans le monde et ça a aimé
700 millions de tonnes de CO2 donc
pas la filière aéronautique elle est
partie du principe que elle veut
résoudre le problème de manière globale
elle veut pas juste exporter son CO2 le
mettre sur le dos de quelqu'un d'autre
donc
il faut l'hydrogène ensuite le CO2
capturé il y a des des filières très
prometteuses de capture de CO2
mais on n'est pas encore au CE2
industriel
il y a d'autres manières de faire des if
you
avec
des réserves de carbone
naturelle le bois
on passe on peut passer par une étape
d'éthanol enfin il y a pas mal de
formules mais tout ça n'est pas encore
industrialisé
et en particulier on ne sait pas encore
quel est le coût
quel est le prix moyen d'un litre de
kérosène ou d'un litre de carburant
obtenu de cette manière tout d'abord
parce qu'on ne sait pas quel volume on
est capable de produire plus on fait du
volume plus les prix baisse donc c'est
pas mûr mais c'est pas pour autant que
il ne faut pas poursuivre la filière les
ingénieurs savent tout faire donc j'ai
aucun problème on peut y arriver
ça c'est sur l'aspect sur l'aspectif
sur l'aspect hydrogène
de la même manière que les ingénieurs
savent tout faire en matière de de
synthèse de carburant les ingénieurs
seront faire voler un avion avec de
l'hydrogène
seront stockés de l'hydrogène dans les
aéroports sauront
transportés de l'hydrogène pour refuer
pour fioler des avions
il se trouve que là aussi la maturité
et surtout la disponibilité de cette
hydrogène on fait l'hypothèse c'est un
hydrogène décarbonée
fait que si on veut tenir le calendrier
2035 pour le premier avion qui vole 0
carbone et 2050 une aviation des
carbonées on a on a estimé que le
meilleur compromis c'était pas plus de
13% du budget de de
décarbonation 100% c'est le volume
actuel et la projection dans le temps du
volume de CO2 ou du du de la masse de
CO2 émise ça c'est 100% on a estimé que
13% de ça sera traité en 2050 par
des nouvelles technologies c'est alors
soit l'hydrogène soit l'électrique en
fait une combinaison des deux
ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne sait pas
faire ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne fera
pas plus tard plus c'est juste pour
tenir les délais
et le dernier élément de réponse à votre
question ou à vos questions c'est est-ce
qu'il y a alignement entre
Airbus et Boeing
quelques années quand j'étais chez
Airbus j'aurais répondu j'avais de la
vie on est on fait tout différent et
nous on fait mieux
qu'un peu de recul finalement c'est un
duopole
et le duopole la façon de fonctionner
elle est très simple il y en a un qui
prend une initiative et l'autre qui la
suit et il dit
celui qui suit dit je suis mais je fais
mieux
ça a été l'histoire d'Airbus et de
Boeing depuis 70
qui veut la parole oui poser une
question tu te présentes
puisque j'étais le député maire de la
ville d'Albert pendant 30 ans et on a un
établissement néolt j'avais jamais eu
l'occasion de vous rencontrer donc il
faut que je vienne au sein maintenant
pour pour vous rencontrer
je voudrais revenir sur la sur la
question de Vincent capocanella ce
concernant
Boeing et Airbus vous dites quand
quelqu'un démarre une initiative il y a
l'autre qui qui déclenche la même etc
est-ce que sur un sujet comme celui-là
il n'y a pas moyen de de se parler de se
mettre d'accord de grouper donc des
énergies de cerveau pour essayer
d'avancer sur ce sujet là
ma première question parce qu'ils ont
tout intérêt à faire en sorte que ce duo
pôle survive bien entendu
et la deuxième question qui est qui qui
est derrière celle-ci c'est les
motoristes est-ce qu'ils ont décidé de
travailler aussi ensemble sur ces sujets
là ça fera pratique est-ce qu'ils ont
décidé de travailler ensemble ou est-ce
que chacun mène ses recherches dans son
propre coin
alors il y a deux questions dans votre
question tout d'abord les avionnaires
pour des raisons de de concurrence le
seul domaine dans lequel les avionneurs
sont autorisés à se parler et d'ailleurs
il se parle très activement ils
échangent c'est la sécurité des vols
donc les avionneurs aujourd'hui ne se
parlent pas ils n'ont pas le droit de se
parler sur l'aspect
des carbonations
bon maintenant on va pas
on va pas se raconter d'histoires les
avions ne se parlent pas mais ils ont en
commun les motoristes parce que quand
vous êtes CFM vous vous équipez les deux
quand vous êtes Rolls-Royce vous équipez
les deux quand vous êtes GI vous équipez
les deux
prêtez Whitney pour l'instant et qui
perbus mais prêté Whitney équipe
l'aviation militaire aux États-Unis donc
il y a pas de travail il y a pas de
groupe de travail Airbus Boing sur la
décarbonation mais là où les
préoccupations se rencontrent et là où
il y a beaucoup de travail qui est fait
en commun
sécher les motoristes
même si les motoristes ne travaillent
pas entre eux Ji et safran oui au sein
de CFM
c'est assez peu de projets communs
aujourd'hui entre les entre les moteurs
il faut imaginer les motoristes d'avion
il y a les petits moteurs les gros
moteurs je parle d'avion commerciaux
encore une fois désolé de ne pas traiter
toute l'aéronautique il y a les
l'aviation d'affaires il y a l'aviation
militaire dont on parle pas beaucoup
mais qui elle aussi doit passer
à cette approche de décarbonation
mais si on prend l'aviation commerciale
vous avez les petits moteurs les gros
moteurs dans les petits moteurs il y en
a deux CFM c'est à dire j safran
est prêté
et dans les gros moteurs vous en avez
deux Rolls-Royce et J
il travaille pas ensemble ils sont en
concurrence et de la même manière que
Airbus eboing ne peuvent pas se parler
pour des raisons de concurrence c'est
plus un peu plus facile pour les
motoristes il y a eu des approches il y
a eu des projets communs mais c'est ça
reste assez séparé
maintenant si vous descendez d'un cran
là aussi ils ont des sous-traitants
communs et donc c'est c'est là que se
passe le travail collectif
s de suivre un petit peu et ça rejoint
un peu ce qu'on avait vu à Lyon où la
recherche avance avance dans tous les
domaines vous parlez d'aéronautique dans
la vie aussi pour la motorisation des
véhicules lourds etc et à un moment
donné il va falloir faire des priorités
parce que ce qui est vrai c'est que s'il
y a des évolutions au niveau de
l'hydrogène il y a des évolutions au
niveau des biocarburants mais est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas pour que ça passe au
niveau technique et industriel parce que
là c'est vraiment le souci c'est des
finances et faire des choix est-ce qu'il
y aurait pas une gradation de de
l'évolution de de la enfin de carburant
c'est à dire commencer par des
biocarburants qui vont être peut-être
plus facile à mettre en place et ensuite
passer à l'hydrogène avec des techniques
qui vont évoluer encore je ne sais pas
est-ce que c'est peut-être un choix
politique mais quel est votre sentiment
là c'est exactement c'est exactement ce
que ce que ce à quoi je faisais allusion
en réponse à monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une question de majorité dans le
temps il faut commencer je dès l'année
prochaine
il faut augmenter la proportion de de
carburant durable dans les avions
il faut augmenter sachant qu'on peut
aller jusqu'à 100 % même si la
certification n'est pas faite au-delà de
j'ai aucun doute qu'on peut aller
jusqu'à 100 c'est juste la disponibilité
de la matière première et poursuivre la
recherche pour suivre le travail
technique le travail industriel sur
toutes les filières c'est ce n'est pas
du Soi soit il faut il faut les deux il
faut avancer et puis progressivement
faire du faire faire les
l'introduction
l'insertion technologique comme on dit
manière un peu pédante dans le milieu
industriel il faut insérer les nouvelles
technologies dans les systèmes existants
là-dessus la filière est très claire sur
le fait qu'il faille le faire un peu
dans l'ordre maintenant il y a une
question que vous n'avez pas posée mais
que je me permets de de vous soumettre
qui est que non seulement il va falloir
faire des choix
dans au sein de la filière aéronautique
mais il va falloir
qu'il y ait des priorités
filières de transport par filière de
transport
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui c'est très
commode
pour du transport lourd là où vous avez
du volume là vous avez de la place
ça serait gâché que de dire on va faire
du transport lourd avec des carburants
durables parce que les carburants
durables qu'on va brûler dans les dans
les gros camions ou dans les dans les
bateaux ou dans les ou dans les dans les
trains ne sera plus disponible pour
l'aéronautique
l'électrique et commode pour le pour
l'automobile
si on dit NON NON l'automobile va
fonctionner avec du carburant durable là
aussi c'est du carburant durable qui
n'ira pas à l'aviation
l'aviation est sans doute le mode de
transport le plus contraignant
pour des raisons pour des raisons de
poids le poids et l'ennemi de la viande
même si l'ordre Kelvin avait tort de
penser qu'on ne pouvait pas faire voler
un plus lourd que l'air
il vaut mieux qu'il soit pas beaucoup
plus lourd que l'air parce que s'il est
beaucoup plus lourd que l'air il décolle
pas ou alors il décolle en consommant
beaucoup d'énergie
donc il y a l'arbitrage il est au sein
de chaque filière de transport il est
entre filières de transport
sur une épaule Savary sénateur de la
Marne
qui peut le faire finalement l'arbitrage
parce que quand on écoute les
différentes filières chacune a des voix
alors qui peuvent être relativement
identique
vous si j'ai bien compris les les
moteurs sont transformables
en suivant l'évolution des carburants
sauf les moteurs électriques sauf les
moteurs
l'avion électrique
monsieur le sénateur et c'est formidable
on a chez Airbus on a on a eu le premier
franchissement de la Manche par un avion
électrique c'était il y a plus de 10 ans
donc c'est pas
le premier avion électrique je crois a
volé
au tout début du siècle
du 20e pas du 21e donc c'est pas c'est
pas une innovation majeure le problème
de l'avion électrique c'est que
l'énergie embarquée ne permet pas de
transporter beaucoup de fret ou beaucoup
de poids quand jean-bottis à traverser
la Manche avec un avion électrique ils
étaient deux à bord
et aujourd'hui les analyses montrent que
un avion électrique de plus de 20
passagers c'est ça reste une chimère ou
alors il faut embarquer une centrale
nucléaire à bord avec
avec d'autres problèmes un crash parce
que la certification il faut pas
seulement tenir compte du fonctionnement
normal il faut se tenir compte du
fonctionnement dégradé donc
il y a une voie pour l'électrique dans
les 13% que j'ai évoqués tout à l'heure
il y a un bout d'électrique parce qu'il
y a une certaine partie de l'aviation
qu'on peut électrifier l'entraînement
des avions où il y a deux trois quatre
passagers
certaines liaisons d'affaires
ça c'est jouable en électrique
l'avion de 100 places ou de l'avion de
200 places électriques
en tout cas moi je ne le verrai pas
et d'autre part dans l'organisation des
filières c'est des filières qui
pouvaient être organisées mieux
organisés effectivement il faut aller
chercher un peu la biomasse dans des
territoires relativement là mais il faut
l'organiser peut-être de façon éphémère
avec la transformation justement et
éventuellement demain les fioul par
rapport au biocarburant donc ça veut
dire que on peut des fois
être amené à organiser des filières pour
quelques années qui seraient vite
obsolètes
ça ne sera pas la première fois dans
l'histoire des technologies et des
industries que des
des évolutions ou des solutions
ont été éphémères pendant des siècles la
marine était à voile aujourd'hui il nous
viendrait pas à l'idée de revenir à la
voile même si certains disent c'est la
façon la plus efficace c'est la plus
renouvelable
Bernard
merci monsieur le Président j'ai deux
questions simples la première c'est
comment faire une filière en France
justement de carburant pour l'aviation
du rap parce que on a le sentiment qu'il
y a un problème déjà d'investissement
et que les pouvoirs publics comment dire
sans être désagréable sont un peu
tétanisés quand même devant l'ampleur
des financements qu'il faut mobiliser
pour bâtir ses filières et avoir ce que
vous avez indiqué c'est un des
déraffineries
spéciales et avoir toute cette chaîne là
on a un peu le sentiment que il y a
aussi la crainte de mettre des fonds
publics pour dire les choses clairement
sur la filière aéronautique pour des
raisons d'images aujourd'hui mais déjà
est-ce que vous avez sentiments que on
peut alors je vais pas vous dire ticket
mais qu'on peut mobiliser du financement
privé et qu'on peut bâtir un système
vertueux avec l'État pour arriver ça
c'est la première question je réponds
les industriels de l'énergie les gens
qui ont des raffineries
aujourd'hui ils sont pas contre
faire du faire du hifioul encore une
fois c'est une question d'investissement
et l'investissement il n'y a pas
d'investissement 100% public ou
d'investissement 100% privé il y a c'est
à partir du moment où on est d'accord
sur une sur une direction à prendre
tout le monde investit
l'investissement public c'est plutôt
dans des choses long terme dans des
choses
où le retour n'est pas immédiat
investissement privé il est dans le il
est dans des dans des démarches dont le
retour est plus et plus et plus proche
il y a des fonds
savent donc
carburant d'aviation durable qui sont en
train de s'organiser qui sont en train
de se monter ils sont pas encore montés
mais il y en a donc il y a des privés
qui disent c'est un secteur dans lequel
je vais regarder pour pour trouver mon
pour trouver mon
pour trouver mon bonheur si j'ose dire
d'investisseurs mais ce à quoi je ne
crois pas c'est une situation où c'est
que le privé
ou que le public
il va bien falloir qu'on qu'on sorte de
ce de ces chiens de faïence qui se
regardent et qui disent bon qui va
commencer vous avez dit quelque chose
qui qui est assez caractéristique
de ce qui nous bloque aujourd'hui vous
avez dit les pouvoirs publics
pourraient répugnier à mettre de
l'argent dans
l'aéronautique pour des questions de
réputation mais justement on est en
train de décarboner l'aviation
donc là le problème de réputation lui ne
devrait pas nous bloquer je rappelle
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé par ça
tout à l'heure dans mon propos liminaire
c'est une des
seuls filières d'excellence
en France et dans une certaine mesure en
Europe de l'Ouest donc on va pas on va
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du vin on
va pas on va pas sacrifier pour des
questions de réputation quelque chose
qui
qui fait qu'on est leader mondial
quelque part
merci sur
la question qu'on entend quand même
régulièrement de la décroissance alors
vous avez tout à l'heure rappelé il y
avait une aspiration à se déplacer ça
faisait partie des grandes libertés et
des grandes aspirations mais quand même
on entend un certain nombre qui nous
disent par exemple si on va dire
carburant aéronautique à partir de
biomasse ou autre on va dire à
certainement pas pour l'aérien bon on va
entendre ce genre de choses et on a ce
propos là alors
pendant longtemps pardon comment vous
réagissez par rapport à cette théorie
décroissance de l'aérien puis
deuxièmement quand même
l'avantage des carburants la version
durable c'est sans doute qu'il y a pas
une grosse rupture technologique après
tout avoir du kérosène on aura des
fioules bon c'est pas si c'est pas rien
il faut les faut monter raffineries il
faut des solutions il faut arriver à
quand même à ce que ça marche c'est déjà
pas si mal mais
est-ce qu'il y aura pas des innovations
plus plus fortes quand même qui peuvent
intervenir je reviens un peu là dessus
plus forte c'est certain c'est juste que
dans le timing
2035-2050 l'essentiel de la
décarbonation sera carburant durable
la décroissance ne se le rapporteur
c'est c'est une c'est un acte c'est une
c'est un choix idéologique moi j'ai fait
le choix inverse
j'ai fait le choix inverse non pas
pour des raisons irrationnelles mais
pour des raisons complètement
rationnelles je vais demander faudrait
qu'on fasse un sondage sur le milliard
482 millions d'Indiens pour savoir
combien d'entre eux
seraient prêts à troquer
la liberté que le ramène le fait de
pouvoir voyager et voyager en avion
contre
d'autres objectifs on va demander aux
milliards 436 millions de Chinois l'Inde
vient de passer devant la Chine en
termes de population mondiale donc c'est
c'est un moment un moment important dans
l'histoire de l'humanité on va demander
aux 350 millions d'Indonésiens
parce que c'est eux qui voyagent faut
pas faut pas faut pas qu'on se raconte
l'histoire les Européens voyagent les
Français voyagent mais c'est de plus en
plus une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan de la mobilité
et donc je reviens là aussi à mon propos
liminaire ou bien on prend la tête de la
transformation ou bien on sera dépassé
par d'autres parce que le besoin de
voyage est un besoin irrépressible
et un poids auquel je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas à la capacité je ne crois même
pas à la
à la pertinence et à la légitimité des
Européens de dire aux Indiens aux
Chinois et aux indonésiens vous savez
quoi vous ne voyagerez plus
dans l'écosystème là du transport aérien
qui va payer
tout ça va coûter
le passager
étonnamment le passager déjà paye
en 2023
plus qu'il ne paye en 2000 puisqu'il ne
payant en 2019
je dis étonnamment parce qu'il y a en
nombre de passagers en r en
pas tout à fait le nombre de passagers
mais en RPK en revenu par passager par
km
on est au dessus de là où on était en 19
dans le monde entier
ça montre bien que ce bien au sens
économique du terme qui est la mobilité
est un bien que le
les hommes les êtres humains valorisent
plus que ne le valoriser peut-être
l'écosystème transport aérien avant le
covid
maintenant il faut éviter il y a une
limite c'est à dire qu'il y a une
certaine élasticité mais au-delà de
laquelle
le système s'écroule d'où tous mes
commentaires et tous mes raisonnements
autour de quel volume de ifioul quel
volume de
carburant durable quel volume
d'hydrogène vert quels volumes
d'hydrogène bleue pour faire en sorte
que le prix au litre soit abordable et
acceptable par l'écosystème
je n'ai pas de chiffre là parce que
c'est celui qui a les chiffres je pense
qu'il est
je pense qu'il a il gagne le gros lot
d'une certaine manière mais
est-ce que un prix de carburant durable
un prix du litre du carburant durable si
les deux fois trois fois cinq fois dix
fois
supérieur
à ce qu'est un litre de carburant
fossile est-ce que le prix au kilomètre
d'une propulsion hydrogène si elle est
deux fois cinq fois
100 fois c'est quoi la limite je ne sais
pas
sans doute que deux trois cinq
ça reste abordable
mais je peux pas je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas je ne sais pas
une certaine manière il faut retrouver
l'humilité de l'approche scientifique et
quand on ne sait pas dire je ne sais pas
et dire je cherche
question indirecte mais le choix
européen de choisir le moteur
électrique pour les voitures à l'horizon
2035 sans abandonnant complètement le
moteur thermique va dans le sens que ça
libère pour vous
des biocarbures ou des carburants
nouveaux qui facilitent aux activités ou
est-ce que c'est pas forcément le bon
choix
je ne suis pas un expert de l'automobile
donc je
ma réponse forcément c'est pour ça que
je vous la pose et biaisé entaché de
d'inexactitude mais personnellement je
ne crois pas
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
décider comme ça par un
par un oukase de haut en bas que à telle
date il n'y aura plus que
je pense que en revanche que dire la
priorité en matière de transport
automobile
doit être électrique sur le plan
technique sur la vue d'un ingénieur ça
fait du sens parce que une voiture on
peut mettre des batteries et ça
fonctionne et ça fonctionne très bien il
y a pas que Tesla aujourd'hui vous avez
de plus en plus de véhicules électriques
qui sont remarquables si vous prenez de
temps en temps des taxis parisiens qui
sont électriques vous avez des belles
berlines vous avez des petites voitures
et
contrairement à ce qui était prédit
finalement le développement des réseaux
de charge
et correct
est-ce qu'il sera suffisant pour quand
on montera en puissance quand il y aura
une majorité de véhicules électriques je
pense que c'est gérable encore une fois
je ne suis pas spécialiste mais si je
devais faire une allocation simple je
dirais priorité électrique pour le la
petite mobilité terrestre priorité
hydrogène pour la grosse mobilité
terrestre priorité carburant durable
pour la mobilité aérienne vous notez je
dis priorité puisque il y a de
l'hydrogène il y a de l'électrique
il y a aussi enfin mais ils ont le le
poids fort il est dans chaque cas sur un
des sur une des une des modes de
propulsion
oui vous avez dit tout à l'heure que le
choix il y avait un choix difficile à
prendre pour l'aviation française qui
était de choix de la décarbonation et
que la filière fixerait les standards
est-ce que vous croyez qu'à travers
l'aviation du mot à travers le monde
est-ce que est-ce que la France va
l'Europe congé par la France l'Europe
peut avoir cette cette assise et dire
voilà nous on propose ceci est-ce que ça
peut être entendu et réalisable
il y a deux il y a deux façons de fixer
des standards
il y a la façon que vous vous connaissez
bien qui est la normalisation
la législation la réglementation et puis
il y a les standards dit de fait
quand vous êtes leader mondial que vous
avez de l'avance que vous livrez
des avions électriques avant les autres
que vous livrez des avions un carburant
durable avant les autres ou des
véhicules électriques avant les autres
ou en fait vous fixez le standard sans
normalisation
je crois beaucoup à la combinaison des
deux c'est à dire qu'il faut être en
avance techniquement
pour pour imposer d'une certaine manière
un standard
l'exemple que je cite volontiers c'est
dans les télécoms quand j'étais jeune
ingénieur il y a bien longtemps
il y avait tout un travail de
normalisation des réseaux des réseaux
locaux des réseaux moyens des réseaux
d'entreprises aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
dans les entreprises n'a rien à voir
avec les travaux de normalisation il y a
une sorte de standard de fait qui a été
imposé par celui qui commercialement et
qui technologiquement a offert le plus
vite
la meilleure solution avec les volumes
les plus importants
voilà il faut y aller
il a pris une position officielle sur le
sujet
il y a
il y a évidemment et
après une position
comment dire officielle oui officiel sur
la sur le besoin de décarbonation
il y a tant n'a pas pris de position sur
le choix technologique c'est pas le rôle
de Yatta de faire ça mais ce qui est
remarquable dans cette filière
aéronautique c'est une fois que le
problème est posé
la
convergence des points de vue
alors on diffère un peu sur les dosages
un tout petit peu plus de ceci ou un
type un tout petit peu plus de cela mais
finalement le problème il est sans
problème technique c'est un problème
industriel la solution elle est claire
il faut y aller on y va
mon évoque toujours la concurrence
Boeing Airbus on fait toujours des
comparaisons entre l'Europe les
États-Unis on est parfois un peu
masochiste et on a tous entendu avec
l'iral les États-Unis près d'une
longueur d'avance on va être dépassé bon
l'Europe annonce un centre de choses
c'est un point de vue là dessus sur la
manière d'aider l'industrie et puis
d'aider le secteur aussi à faire sa
transition écologique est-ce que voilà
la mobilisation est vous paraît
suffisante en Europe et singulièrement
en France et puis en termes
d'accompagnement financier vous allez
regarder des cas particuliers pour aider
les entreprises ou dans l'industrie
actuelle les constructeurs à faire cette
mutation là est-ce qu'il y a des sujets
de financement à votre connaissance et
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait améliorer
tout ça
vous vous
souvenez sans doute
dès 2015
dès 2015 donc bien avant
la crise bien avant le
gérer la montée en puissance de cette de
ce besoin des carbonation quand on
présentait les investissements de
technologie fait par l'industrie
on mettait en avant le fait que on
parlait pas de décarbonation on parlait
de réduction des émissions
au Bourget au salon du Bourget on
présentait les investissements coracles
que vous avez évoqué en montrant que
70%, 75% de la RFT donc rechercher
technologies
des grands donneurs d'ordre étaient
tournés vers la était tournée vers la
décarbonation vers la réduction des
émissions pardon c'est ce qu'on disait
15 17 19
aujourd'hui on est passé
on a passé une vitesse supérieure au
fond puisqu'on dit décarbonation
c'est-à-dire 0 carbone
alors
si on se compare
la comparaison elle est pas tranchée
entre l'IRA et les paquets européens
si j'exclus
le les financements de l'aviation civile
française
il y a quand même une tendance
européenne
a punir plutôt qu'à inciter
et ce qui est
remarquable avec le mécanismes
américains ont focalise sur l'irra mais
les mécanismes aux États-Unis c'est le
côté incitatif
alors ça serait quand même un peu
dommage que
ayant donné le ayant lancé le mouvement
on se fasse dépasser
par des mécanismes plus efficaces du
côté du côté nord-américain
plus efficace parce que plus facile à
décider par un État fédéral au fond
et parce que il y a toujours cet esprit
c'est une différence que je constate
dans mon métier aujourd'hui en tant
qu'investisseur parce que je n'investis
pas que dans l'aéronautique il y a une
tendance assez forte en Europe à réguler
et une tendance assez forte aux
États-Unis a incité
il faudrait rééquilibrer un peu
sur la question
du
je dirais du
contenu et de la
trouve je cherche les mots là parce que
je veux pas dire de pas dire de choses
excessives mais sur la question du
bon dosage entre réglementation et
incitation
vous savez comme moi que
il n'y en a pas vraiment d'instantané on
peut pas dire c'est ça
je constate qu'il y a plus de
réglementations plus de restriction de
ce côté-ci de l'Atlantique et qu'il
faudrait aller plus loin dans les
entreprises
aujourd'hui on n'a pas investi
spécifiquement sur la décarbonation mais
chaque fois qu'on investit dans une
usine
je reviens à ticket au capital
investissant dans
mecacrom Figeac
je dis des noms pardon si j'en oublie il
y en a énormément chaque fois qu'on
investit dans une usine on investit dans
une logique des carbonée des
carbonations de la production des
carbonations de de la de l'énergie
utilisée
[Musique]
toutes les entreprises du de notre
portefeuille
sont astreintes à une collection
d'informations sur les émissions avec un
objectif de réduction de ses émissions
dans leur mode dans leur mode
d'opération je ne parle même pas de la
décarbonation des avions puisque la
décarbonation des avions la conception
la décarbonation des avions appartient
rarement aux sous-traitants elle
appartient plutôt aux avionnaires en
motoristes mais c'est
tout le monde est aligné vers l'objectif
0 carbone
peut-être d'autres questions j'en ai une
sur le fond peut-être plus politique
c'est que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que le carburant durable comme la
décarbonation c'était quand même dans un
temps long
or vous avez dit aussi que les
ingénieurs savent tout faire il suffit
de leur poser les bons problèmes
on est bien dans une situation de crise
énergétique dans le monde mais en France
en particulier en Europe et on voit bien
que ceci n'est pas près de s'arranger
est-ce qu'on peut réduire ce temps
aujourd'hui alors d'un côté il y a une
volonté je vais dire environnementale
sociétale de dire décarbonant en 2035
2050 mais il y a aussi les conditions
économiques pour le faire donc vous
disiez aussi que pour être
des coûts pour être compétitifs sont
plus importants le plus important pour
décider des choix que vous voulez faire
et de la dynamique vous les donner il
est évident que si il faut peut-être
soustraire cette idée du coup tant qu'on
n'a pas développé et voilà et est-ce que
l'État vous accompagne dans cette mesure
est-ce que l'Europe vous accompagne
est-ce que on peut pas faire tout tout
seul quoi c'est pas possible
vous avez vous avez parfaitement sur le
président le
qui est important dans à mon à mes yeux
et ce que je mettais en avance ce n'est
pas le coup de la décarbonation
c'est avec quelle vitesse on est capable
de produire suffisamment de carburant
durable suffisamment d'hydrogène enfin
suffisamment de nous on va dire de
nouveau moyen de propulsion des
carbonées pour que le coût unitaire pour
le passager puisqu'on a dit que c'est
finalement bon que le coût unitaire pour
le passager soit supportable c'est ce
coup-là qui est important le coût de la
décarbonation les industriels chacun a
son niveau ils ont compris que c'était
fondamental si on veut rester leader
est-ce que l'État nous accompagne
habituellement un industriel dit oui
mais pas assez au fond
quand je me regarde je me désole et
quand je me compare je me console ce que
l'État fait pour la filière française
aéronautique française au travers du
corail c'est remarquable quand on le
compare aux autres aux autres nations
encore faut-il que ça continue et c'est
c'est
là peut-être m'a ma petite inquiétude
c'est de dire il faut pas que ça
s'arrête au prétexte parce qu'il y a
toujours ce prétexte qui a invoqué
l'aéronautique c'est une filière riche
bah oui on est premier on est premier
mondiaux donc quand on est premier
mondiaux c'est normal qu'on soit riche
la filière nucléaire française était la
première au monde il y a une quinzaine
d'années
et aujourd'hui on voit où ce côté
débrouillez-vous peut mener
je dis pas que c'est la position de
l'état non le gouvernement nous soutient
mais il y a toujours cette pointe
d'inquiétude on entend on entend souvent
très souvent vous l'avez entendu j'en
suis sûr ah mais eux l'aéronautique ça
va mais non justement c'est parce que ça
va qu'il faut continuer de soutenir
c'est un peu l'image du sportif à un
sportif il travaille ses points forts il
travaille pas ses points faibles j'avais
dit tout à l'heure que ça allait
beaucoup mieux
ça va ce qui va ce qui va bien c'est le
trafic c'est la demande
aujourd'hui la demande et là les gens
veulent voyager
j'ai pas insisté sur la demande mais il
y a des il y a des il y a des canards
dont on a tortu le coup assez rapidement
une des choses qu'on entendait en 2020
c'est il y aura plus jamais de voyage
d'affaires
la proportion de voyage d'affaires
aujourd'hui est la même que celle de
et on voyage plus qu'en 2019
alors les esprits chagrins vous diront
oui mais c'est pas du vrai voyage
d'affaires c'est du voyage d'agrément
c'est du voyage d'affaires puisque les
Business Class des avions sont pleines
et les avions sont pleines merci de
merci Philippe les avions sont plein le
taux de remplissage des avions n'a
jamais été aussi bon et les prix des
billets sont 30% plus cher en moyenne
que ce qu'ils étaient en 2019
ça veut dire que ce délai on peut le
raccourcir le délai
le délai le délai
le délai
demain matin demain matin si on avait si
on avait cherché on avait une baguette
magique c'est-à-dire si on avait un
montant infini d'investissement
on saurait faire une une usine qui
produit
la question c'est quel est le taux
d'adoption qui va faire le volume qui va
faire que le prix au litre sera
compétitif pour les compagnies aériennes
et donc pour les passagers
un grand merci de on aimerait vous
entendre encore plus longtemps mais vous
avez d'autres obligations et merci
d'être venu ici ce soir merci à nos
collègues d'être là Bernard t'avais pas
une question à poser voilà je vous
remercie et merci de rapporteur qui aime
bien noté
merci beaucoup de questions et si vous
avez des éléments à nous envoyer je vais
faire le tour des questions si jamais il
y a des choses que j'ai que j'ai
commises je me permettrai de vous les
adresser merci infiniment